and joining us from phoenix after
calling game one of the nba finals last
night with mark jackson
and uh mike breen as well uh jeff van
gundy back here on the rich eyes and
show how are you jeff
man that brought back great memories
rich thanks for playing that it really
did
um it was a such a a cherished moment
for me to be able to speak to greatness
like coach wooden
and uh sometimes you forget all the
blessings you've had and so that was
that was wow that was great yeah you
know i love that story that you told uh
you know when i guess it was in october
2019 when you were on here that uh
you're a big wooden fan and walton's
like oh let me get them on the phone
which is a nice flex for walton to just
be able to do
and that and it just that had to be
really cool for you to know that he was
giving you
like i'm seeing your games and i see
you're posting up spreewell and allen
houston a lot i like to see him uh
playing facing the basket that he's
watching your stuff that's amazing
he said it in such a like uh remarkably
uh with with remarkable both
humility and conviction like you're not
really that smart if you don't do what i
say but i'm not gonna make you feel bad
for being a dummy you know
and now uh let's talk about the here and
now with monty williams i
i it's just amazing and it's fun to
watch uh
a team uh buy completely 100 percent
what a coach is selling what what is
monty williams selling that works so
well
with this team in in phoenix jeff van
gundy
well i've had uh i had the great
pleasure of being able to coach monty
uh as an assistant coach uh for a year
and a half his rookie year and then
halfway into his second year and
the thing that i think
separate or not separates him but makes
him such a great head coach besides the
the normal basketball knowledge is
he is a phenomenal leader and i can't
emphasize that enough he is
honest he is direct he is
humble he has great empathy
and um he's got
as much as as much integrity as anyone
uh in the nba at any position in the nba
so those characteristics and those
qualities
make him a phenomenal leader and so if
you're a phenomenal leader and you have
great basketball knowledge
you position yourself to get the most
out of your team
and they have a terrific team james
jones has put together a terrific roster
and monty williams has driven home
exactly what wins and loses in this
league
and um it's just so
i am so happy for him it's uh he should
be very proud of himself
and and the one thing that just strikes
me jeff because again
i'm i'm i'm watching at home and then
i'm seeing and i'm hearing what goes on
in a huddle and how he also um
speaks uh during you know quarter breaks
and thing
he he always seems very calm and
and it seems like he doesn't raise his
voice and even when the crowd's going
crazy thank goodness we have full arenas
again
that's got to be something that's
contagious as well for a team i would
imagine
jeff well he he preaches poise uh
constantly
and he is the great
he emanates that message by how he
conducts himself so
he conducts himself with great poise
thus his team
has uh an everyday reminder of what
poise
under pressure looks like and because of
all of his life experiences
i think he know he knows exactly how
much basketball matters
or should matter in someone's life and i
think that also gives him
uh grace and poise uh
in these stressful moments but because
he's faced so
many more stressful moments in his life
he's able to
conduct himself with the appropriate
level of
poise but also don't mistake that for
not being an intense
fiery competitor because he is he had
great edge as a player
and he continues to have this great edge
uh as a coach
you know and me becoming from the nfl
world jeff jeff van gundy here
it he it's the same thing that i heard
was always said about tony dungy
that this you're you know the word grace
poise
uh you know fiery competitor as a player
bringing that to
a a head coach and
demanding accountability without being
the loudest person in the room
honestly like that that sounds the same
thing to me to be honest with you yeah
and i think the the common denominator
there
is they they're men of great faith and
who also
again both have experienced
um gut-wrenching tragedies in their life
and so their faith plus the tragedy i
think
you know tragedies give them this uh
perspective
of what their bigger purpose in life is
is
which is to impact uh the people around
them and
they both to me when i think of servant
leadership
the two two names that pop to my mind
are tony dungy
and monty williams and um uh
i listen i i have as much respect for
monty williams the person
as you can have for another person and
um
he is truly when we're looking uh
for american heroes
he's an am he though the way he conducts
himself
on an everyday basis uh it gives me
great pride
that i know him and i and and rick i'm a
lot older than him
but i learned from him i watch him and
this isn't this year
he's been a terrific assistant coach
i thought he did a great job in new
orleans and
and now he's doing obviously a great job
here where people are recognizing
what he's doing but i learned from him
way back when he was a player all the
way through now because
just because of how he conducts himself
jeff van gundy here on the rich eisen
show phoning in from uh phoenix where
the suns took game one and a lot of
people might be hearing our conversation
right now jeff and i think that we're
at least i'm coming across as sounding
you know a little bit
uh a sense of inevitability about the
outcome of this series it is just one
game but i'm wondering if it just
maybe because it's chris paul and it
just feels like it's his time
it just feels like he's he's not being
stopped by the usual things that
that cut him short with injury or in the
case of covid
that he just you know finished it the
the clippers with the 41
uh piece and dropped a 32 piece in game
one it just seems like
he's on fire right now um and not to be
stopped jeff well these second halfs
have been phenomenal these last two
games i mean
you know the shooting numbers uh
and what chris paul combines is
uh when he's right is remarkable
offensive efficiency
and a ruthless competitor those two
things
are hard to find in combination but we'd
all be making a mistake if we
overreact to one game i i think
the bucks have to get better play from
holiday in particular uh milton's got to
get started
sooner you know the last the closeout
game against atlanta and last night
uh very very below average first half
and then great second half he's got to
get started quicker
and then you know how does
andenna cumpo how does he react to game
one is he okay still
um you know is he able to play at a high
level
i thought he looked great and i also
thought phoenix did a great job on it
so i mean i thought you know both things
you know he had a very good game
considering all the circumstance but he
did not
overwhelm um
phoenix at all i thought their defense
was
rock solid when it came to giannis
what do you make of the sense of
the conversation and surrounding the
bucks despite their
making the nba finals that middleton
does neet as you mentioned get started
sooner and he has to be the guy
to finish up late because giannis is
that mvp
who is such a liability from the line
that
that he can't be the guy who has the
ball in his hands in crunch time and
that's the ultimate problem with the
bucks what do you make of that
sense jeff van gundy well i think in you
know one possession games
which you know a lot of times in the
regular season
you're when you're as good as the bucks
are you're playing from ahead right so
uh a shot here a missed free throw there
you know you can overcome that but if
you're in hard fought
one possession playoff games uh what you
try to do with your roster
is play to your players greatest
strengths
and hide their non-strengths and i think
obviously
one of giannis's non-strengths is his
free throw shooting
and middleton has a
offensive game where he's got the
ability
to shoot it deep which we've seen he's
got the mid-range pull-up game
uh he can get all the way to the basket
with his size and finish
and he's a an improving passer right so
he has the whole package so it's not
really a knock on
giannis that we're not going to go to
often times late in one possession games
but we we're going to play to
middleton's greatest strength that
doesn't mean giannis won't take the shot
or get an offensive rebound or run a
pick and roll and create a play
but the free throw shooting uh issues
are real
and you know you you can't
throw away like if you're up one down
one
you know most likely you can't take the
chance
of him getting fouled and having to
knock in too it's just
it's smart coaching it's smart
basketball to use your roster
uh and that doesn't detract from giannis
being
a great great player but it's using a
special offensive player in middleton
appropriately
jeff van gundy here on the rich eisen
show last one for you jeff
um and uh uh this is a subject that i
know is near and dear to you
uh because i i pick up what you put down
during your broadcast i have a
four-point plan to improve nba replay
jeff van gundy and i want to i can i i
i'm for it
i already know i'm recording go ahead
okay here's a one point plan right let
me go don't say get rid of it don't say
get rid of it
unless it's the last shot of the game
and or land and the three-point line or
two-point shot that we can do on the fly
okay okay that's my one point playing go
with your four
okay here's my four-point plan because
you know i'm an
nfl replay expert i really feel i should
be on the competition committee and i
i will use whatever uh juice i may have
in any way shape or form or pulp with
roger goodell to one day be
uh enshrined if you will on that
competition committee but i
i've got four points here okay jeff my
first one
first one there's a rule change if
you can be awarded the ball in replay
you can refuse the replay in other words
what happened with the clippers in the
valley oop where the ball was
off of los angeles and they stopped the
game to see if los
angeles could get the ball in the
interim monty williams is able to huddle
up and walk everyone through the valley
oop
paces the clippers could have said screw
that we don't want the replay
get this phoenix suns on the floor right
now they can't huddle up what do you
think of that
well you can decline the replay it's a
it's a good
thought my plan supersedes yours
well look your plan would supersede that
anyway all right
so here's my better part of that though
yes
in addition like you wouldn't even need
your first point if you had
the maxwell smart cone of silence drop
down
where the five players in the game have
to go at the free throw line
and come under the cone of silence at
both ends
okay where they're not allowed to huddle
up would be great sponsorship
we could make some cash and we could
take away
the really illogical extra time out
um that are are being afforded to teams
right so i have a better plan on your
point one point two
okay point two point two is part of the
delay
uh that took forever in that post
valley oop play was figuring out who the
five on the floor need to be put back
out there to make sure it's the same
five
that was on the floor for the valley oop
let's remove scott foster and the rest
of his crew from having to adjudicate
that
it's on the coach to put the right five
on the floor that we're going to go back
out there right away and if you don't
put the right five on the floor it's a
technical foul on you we're not going to
take any more time up on that sort of
nonsense
you really want to end a great game on a
technical foul because a coach
was harried and the wrong guy was on the
floor well i mean
don't be harried you got to have a get
back coach why don't you have somebody
who understands who's on the floor
point two delete okay point three
jeff van gundy point three give uh give
coaches a
replay challenge for the first half
people are people are not challenging
what should be replayed
in the first half because they want to
keep one in their back pocket for the
second half
so you have two two challenges one yes
correct
okay i like that but as an add-on to
that if you get the
if you get it right you keep it and you
can
you know so if i get one right in the
first half i can use another in the
first half
like you shouldn't be punished for being
right
okay i like it that's a that's a nice
little workshop right there jeff van
gogh sort of like the nfl if you get the
first two right you get a third if you
get one of them wrong sorry
okay and here's the last one for you and
i think this one you will
wholeheartedly agree no more stopping
games to chat
to to look at whether something's a
flagrant foul or not no more of that
it's either what you see on the floor
that's it end of story it's flagrant or
not based on first blush
we're not stopping as a pruder film this
thing to see if the wind up or take a
look at intent
anymore i don't want to do that your
thoughts
you know i i'd rather
accept my whole thing is
all of this is decision making we're
trying to make
an imperfect process of officiating
perfect
and it leads to unwieldy delays at times
correct
and so everything from out of bounds
calls it we're afraid they're going to
get it wrong in the
the last two minutes my whole thing is
well we should be worried about the
whole 48 minutes
and and yet we all know that if you have
all this replay
through 48 minutes it it'd be just too
long right correct
the flagrant issue though i think
if the officials didn't use it as a
bailout as much
like they would actually trust their
eyes and
not worry about getting reprimanded by
the powers to be
um and if the powers to be were more
empathetic
to how hard it is to officiate a game
and didn't try to minutely
second guess these guys then we wouldn't
have as many delays
so i don't if they if they didn't just
bail out to go over there
i wouldn't have a problem if they
man was that wind up as as hard as i
think or did the guy flop
um i don't mind that the sticking the
leg under the shooter
um which they got brooke lopez for last
night
i don't even mind that but again once
you open that pandora's box
to me it's too much of a bailout to
always go over there
so i think the referee should only have
like where they can challenge themselves
like once or twice
don't give me the bailout you're paid to
see it you get to go over there once in
the first half
and once in the second half just like
the teams are able to challenge so
challenge yourself
you know hit that green button over
there for yourself right it's not
that one i don't think that's going to
fly but to me it's just again there's so
we're we're trying to see
let's go under the it's a foul we know
it is but is it a common foul or
flagrant film what type of flagrant foul
it is and fans are sitting at home going
let's play
like you called it a foul you know and
and and the number of times that then
you and mark jackson start arguing or
what used to be a common foul and not
it just sounds like a waste of your time
and a waste of everybody's time when
you know first blush i call it a
flagrant too bad like how often is a
replay going to show it wasn't flagrant
when it really is something that's
interpretive
as opposed to you know connecting on a
follow-through by hitting someone in the
face
you know like patrick beverly the
wind-up that
he had he had a up to get up to deandre
ayton's apex
to block most of the ball and then
follow through and hit him in the face
you know what i mean like why stop the
game for that one it actually
got ruled not a flagrant foul right and
so where i thought
was flagrant the officials came back and
said wasn't and actually
i applaud them because again too often i
think right now
you know the officials are under great
scrutiny what i'm saying is
is micromanaged too much which
uh by by their bosses which takes away
feel
and i know officials now in probably
every league but in basketball
they're not encouraged um to have a feel
for the game
which i think is so very important
knowledge of the game
and feel for the game to me gives you
the ability
to know that a certain guy is always
flopping
or you know i got this guy i got to keep
an
eye on because you know history tells me
he's an instigator you know when you see
guys walk up on the guys and bump him in
the back and then a guy react
and you tee up the second guy so i think
this micromanaging
has them on pins and needles as far as
you know if i miss that flagrant foul
you know
owners and and and teams are gonna like
go to the bot my bosses and my bosses
are then going to come down on me and
then
i may get downgraded and not you know
have another playoff game which cost me
money so i think
i think the the the whole
you know paranoia of trying to be
perfect
has actually hurt um the
ability and instincts of our officials
at times
and so i'm all for never going over
there like
but if you are to go over there
i i don't mind going over there on
a flagrant file but again i would just
rather
i know replay is here but replay was
meant
in the nba when it initially came in
for last shot and really these like
high leverage situations and i just
think we've gotten
like all leaks we've just gotten carried
away okay so just to recap um you know
uh replay for flagrant or not is fine as
long as the refs limit themselves
um you you think there should be uh
correct challenges get another challenge
in each half
uh we are dispatching with coaches are
responsible for putting the right people
on the floor
okay and then and then number one is uh
just getting
silent right and just hope that nike
doesn't come up with a shoe phone
to call you know uh to call the coach
from the code of silence come up with
the shoe
phone yes it should be allowed okay
yeah let's not stop technology i agree
with you uh thanks for the call jeff
always appreciate our chats let's chat
down the line have a good rest of the
prompts you guys
jeff van gundy everybody hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here